[Musique]
géraldine hauteur et bonjour bonjour
candidate de la france est soumise dans
le centre atlantique la france est
soumise de jean luc mélenchon avez vous
l'impression madame de torts et qu'une
marche a été ratée ici comme en france
concernant votre mouvement après ce week
end élections alors dans l'absolu oui
c'est une évidence qu'on espérait plus
ceci étant dit on mac traque depuis le
début aux électeurs et aux électrices
martiniquais que c'est en fait une
élection on parle comme si c'était une
élection locale où les candidats et les
candidats de martinique et marc marquez
qui se présente se permettent nos
carrément de ne pas avoir de programme
est mis sur eux en fait sur ce qui les
personnes qu'ils sont le passé qu'ils
ont et c'est donc ça veut dire que en
gros on a dit aux martiniquais ou
martiniquaise voter pour quelqu'un que
vous connaissez qui a fait telle chose
dans la commune et c'est à s'en
expliquer et ça je prends ma part de
responsabilité là dedans sans expliquer
que en fait c'est le député quelqu'un
qui contrôle le parlement vote les lois
et des lois qui ont un impact direct et
donc savoir pour qui on vote c'est à
dire quel est le programme de la
personne qui arrive c'est vraiment
important et qu'il n'avait pas été
briefé propre nom je pense que c'est un
on s'est laissé un peu entraînés dans 20
mois en tout cas je parle pour moi je me
suis laissé un petit peu entraînés dans
les débats dans des choses qui étaient
passard c'est à dire que j'aurais dû
certainement insisté plus vous utilisez
aussi dans la dynamique présidentielle
n'ont pas vrai fait en tout cas je pense
pas on était assez lucide mais ceci dit
on est pas on est on va pas pavoiser
surtout que c'est le taux d'abstention
qui nous est phare qui veut dire c'est
un désaveu tac même ceux qui ont fait
des gros scores il ya quand même un
désaveu général de ce jeu mais ça je ne
sais pas suffisamment clair de la part
de ces sur 53 candidats surnom à peu de
choses près sûrement non mais je vais
pas dire le contraire on n'a pas été
assez clair là dessus oui
mais on a la france a soumises on est on
s'est plutôt pas trop trop c'est pas
trop catastrophique on va dire c'est à
dire qu'on a on existe tout d'un coup
sur l'échiquier politique et qu'il ya
des gens qui ont quand même alors qu'ils
ne me connaissaient pas par exemple qui
ont quand même voté pour la france
insoumise en se fondant j'imagine sur le
programme que nous leur a proposé
l'avenir en commun pour les
présidentielles et parce qu'il savait
pour qui on allait voter en fait c'est
ça aussi l'aventuré s'arrêtera ici
géraldine au toreo ou comptait
poursuivre l'aventuré pour planter
davantage la france à son musicien
martin oui ça c'est très clair nous
allons poursuivre on va on va vraiment
va militer ça veut dire que en fin moi
c'est surtout nous c'est surtout les
extensions donc on va beaucoup
travailler là dessus qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'on va essayer
par exemple de proposer aux gens sur
place des formations pour défendre leur
projet je sais déjà gommer cette
mauvaise question qui a laissé jean luc
mélenchon à l'issue du premier tour de
la présidentielle
quelle mauvaise de kerbala qui ne
savaient pas trop se positionner qu'il
refusait les mains tendues par exemple
de la part des écologistes qui l'a pas
su convaincre les communistes alors
qu'il se présente comme étant la
première force d'opposition
alors là nous il ya une thématique un
petit peu différente en martinique mais
c'est évident que nous allons essayer
nous d'avoir des discussions avec des
parties le problème en martinique c'est
qu'enfin moi ce qui m'a frappé lors des
débats c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de partis
dits de gauche qui envisagent de voter
pour le marché enfin ce que j'appelle le
marché ça veut dire que le gouvernement
qui en place et de voter des lois qui
vont à l'encontre de l'intérêt général
qui défendent les intérêts du marché
donc les intérêts particuliers parce que
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
oui vous comprenez pourquoi les
électeurs sont perdus mais bien sûr mais
bien sûr mais parce que et donc du coup
il ya des gens qui ont bénéficié de pas
tous hein pas tous les députés sont donc
pas tous les gens qui ont été qu'ils
sont en bonne position maintenant sûr
dans ce cas là mais la plupart quand
même sont des gens qui ont eu un
discours extrêmement flou sur leur
positionnement plus tard
donc ça c'est quand même grave lorsqu'il
nous ski ski avant cela ce qui se
présente là c'est vraiment un choix de
société c'est pas juste des trucs
politique des tractations t'es pas sympa
tu votes pour moi aller soit sympa votre
pour moi c'est pas ça c'est vraiment un
choix sur le long terme une orientation
choisie tout ce qu' on perd 10 qui ont
perdu ne veulent pas reconnaître ce
choix emmanuel macron n'est pas arrivé
par accident il a été élu haut la main à
la présidentielle les projections les
projections il a réussi son coup roulé
au troisième tour de la présidentielle
les projections lui donnent une hyper
majorité ce n'est pas un accident
et parce que je pense que d'abord les
son élection coïncide au fait qu'il y
avait en face de lui
marine le pen et qui a quand même
beaucoup de gens qui ont voté contre
marine le pen est pas pour nous habitons
la présidence il a tout ce qui est lu
avant oui il va proposer et comment il a
séduit on peut pas balayer tout cela je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a été
portée par les médias en france de façon
extrêmement clair c'est à dire que
franchement je m'attendais non non c'est
pas la fausse c'est vrai ya deux choses
il ya quand même une couverture
médiatique est très importante 1 une
complaisance médiatique qui quand même
évidente
premièrement mais deuxièmement il ya
quelque chose qui est effectivement plus
importants sur ce je vous rejoins ce
soit vous embêter si vous annoncez votre
si vous me laissez finir fort et ce que
je voulais dire
et d'autre part il ya effectivement le
fait qu' il ya une désespérance c'est à
dire qu'il ya un espèce et que lui il
avait un discours qui était qui
paraissait il c'est quelqu'un de très
agréable qui sait écouter qui arrivait
avec un discours qui paraissait pas
manichéen qui est rassurant parce que le
radicalisme mais est moins rassurant que
le discours non non mais on va composer
tout le monde quand on voit le
gouvernement qui arrive c'est on a quand
même au ministère du travail quelqu'un
qui était la drh de danone
ça c'est des gens qui ont en cause les
accents et de transférer 100 points
mais enfin c'est l'argent qui regroupe
les arrivées aux commandes mais attendez
cinq réacteurs non attendez faire partie
d'un grand groupe arrivé aux commandes
ça veut dire qu'en gros on est formaté
depuis un trail mode depuis longtemps
pour défendre les intérêts d'un groupe
ça veut dire que c'est pas défendre
quand on est drh d'un grand groupe
on n'est pas là pour défendre les
intérêts des employés de ce groupe on
est là pour défendre les intérêts
dessous du groupe qui vous qui vous
payent les électeurs le savent se remet
et le fonctionnement
non c'est à dire que je pense que non
beaucoup de gens il ya encore jeune j'ai
rencontré une jeune femme qui agit
beaucoup pour la martinique qui
s'étaient et qui me dit je crois à
l'entrepreneuriat je pense que c'est pas
la politique qui va sauver le monde et
moi ma réponse a été la suivante et
c'est celle que je qu'on essaie de faire
de façon quotidienne c'est que
l'entrepreneuriat il s'est lassé
mon intérêt moi je suis entrepreneur je
veux réussir moi mon intérêt personnel
ne coïncident pas forcément et parfois
c'est à l'opposé de l'intérêt collectif
et donc ça veut dire que si je fonde ma
politique mais orientations politiques
sur les intérêts particuliers d'un
certain nombre de gens ça peut pas
fonctionner pour les intérêts indique
collectif
le principe c'est que le politique ne
doit pas être au service du marché
le politique doit contrôler le marché à
l'idée de torre voilà pourquoi vous
n'avez pas réussi à expliquer ça aux
électeurs pendant la campagne mais parce
que d'abord je ne suis peut-être pas
assez professionnel de la communication
là dessus et puis d'autre part c'est pas
la question qu'on m'a posée
certes vous là on a le temps en a le
temps on a un petit peu de temps quand
même la manger il est question mais
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas lié avec telle
personne
qu'est-ce que des questions du genre
mais vous êtes qui vous êtes personnes
on m'a pas beaucoup laissé le temps de
parler de choses qui étaient importantes
ça a été quand même un peu de conviction
c'est ce qui manque aux candidats aux à
cette personne on appelle les petits
candidats
savoir se faire entendre je pense qu'il
ya un nez aussi quand même dans un
système
je vous vois venir on est aussi dans un
système qui fait que et c'est là
effectivement vous avez raison il ya une
pratique qui s'acquiert de la gestion
des médias parce que une campagne ne se
joue pas quelques semaines avant le
scrutin tout simplement mais alors
attendez moi je suis quelqu'un qui sait
qui sur le terrain depuis longtemps ya
un moment où même si les conditions ne
sont pas idéales
il faut y aller il faut y aller parce
que justement nous on lutte contre 1,1
quelque chose qui est un rouleau
compresseur très important qui est
l'intérêt particulier posé en intérêt
général et que ça c'est un travail
pédagogique important et qui nécessitent
d'heureux de redonner aux gens le
pouvoir sur leur environnement de leur
faire comprendre qu'ils l'ont ils n'ont
jamais perdu en fait ils l'abandonnent
ils savent pas qu'ils l'ont où il oublie
on le fait croire qu'ils ne l'ont pas
donc ça c'est un travail qu'on va faire
sur le terrain par des choses
extrêmement concrète c'est à dire aider
des gens sur place à défendre des
projets qui sont dans le cadre de cet
intérêt la vie associative
non mais c'est aussi je pense le rôle du
politique d'insuffler un espoir aux gens
c'est à dire leur dire vous voyez on
peut faire quelque chose et donner des
outils et puis par ailleurs je souhaite
rappeler aux politiques que vous l'avez
vu oui désaffection oui mais c'est quoi
le demander c'est quoi l'option cercle
et vous n'êtes quand vous me dites ça je
fais oui danner écrasé et je vais dire
bon ben on va rentrer chez nous et puis
on va aller travailler pour danone un
bon mettons avec danone veuille de moi
m'enfin bon pour quelqu'un d'autre je
jeu c'est pas possible j'ai pas le choix
m'entends personnes qui croient que tout
individu a le pouvoir de changer son
environnement je peux pas rester
immobile et m'occuper aller m'occuper de
mon nombril je suis désolé la france a
soumises va donc tenter de s'implanter
durablement easy un martin oui et nous
allons nous allons travailler de façon
extrêmement étroite avec d'autres partis
de gauche qui se sont clairement qui a
un discours extrêmement claire sur ce
qui se passe sur le gouvernement et des
associations aussi j'en fais partie de
certaines mais d'autres que je vois en
yuans ont des consignes pour le deuxième
tour je possède pas les 4 % en plus je
possède paul dont on est donc enfin
juste ne vous faites attention ne
votaient pas pour des gens qui ont un
discours clair exiger un discours hier
de vos candidats
merci beaucoup je râle ville de torre
candidat de la france est soumise au
cours du week-end dans le centre
atlantique merci bonne journée
[Musique]